more than a month after an altercation
between Clark County School District
police and an officer a student outside
of Durango High School District leaders
were asked to testify before a joint
committee in Carson City today now the
lawmakers just grilled them on current
policies and also pushed for potential
Solutions Sasha Loftus joins us live
outside the Clark County School District
with an update
Denise and Brian we first told you about
this joint meeting earlier today when
district and police leaders discussed
current use of force policies now that
conversation continued into tonight
lawmakers spoke about the changes they'd
like to see
more than a month after this encounter
between a Clark County School District
police officer and a student outside
Durango high school state lawmakers
spoke directly to District leaders
during a hearing in Carson City we also
have to understand the reason this
conversation is happening is because our
constituency came to us and said these
answers aren't happening superintendent
Dr Jesus Jara and CCSD PD Chief Mike
blackeye were in the hot seat Wednesday
speaking on policies and the
Department's reported use of force I
said it here I say it often we have a
lot of work to do while the four-hour
session touched on overall response and
Dr jara's direction to conduct a review
of current policies when a firearm is
near a school we take that very
seriously because there's precious cargo
inside of that building some Senators
pushed for more action I don't see where
we've taken into account that you all
are dealing with children at a school
environment all in what they call an
effort to move forward and keep both
students and officers safe I'd like to
hear what can we do to make all this
better
Dr Jara first announced of use of force
review back on February 13th now CCSD
says each of its officers receive about
40 hours of continuing training each
year reporting live tonight Sasha Loftus
8 News Now